have you ever been to the White House uh
the the one in Washington with the
Cowboys no well have mini you didn't go
to the Cowboys White House no no I did
not that's correct yeah I've been won I
think three 3 times 3 times and okay
give me the reasons the reasons uh got a
tour what two tours through people who I
don't bc one of them was a tour during
the holidays when every room of the
white house is decorated which is just
spectacular is unbelievable and then one
time I was invited I think about four
times then one other time I was invited
when circus won the national
championship and President Bush had all
the teams there I knew somebody the
Communications Office at the White House
and because Syracuse was being honored
they asked me if I wanted to go so my
wife and I were able to go and be there
and see the whole it appears the team
here's your picture with the president
all that good stuff so it's pretty cool
did you take anything oh no no I did eat
lunch at the White House wanted I wanted
to take like silverware or a napkin and
I know that they do a security clearance
when you visit the White House yeah I
just wanted to make sure that I would be
okay on my next security clearance so
that's why I figured let me just leave
everything where it is and I have a
chance to be invited back at some point
uh he's trying to pin i know i have not
know yeah yeah i think i was i think i
was supposed to call a wiffle ball game
on the White House lawn right and then i
think i was invited to and if i was
invited to an event I couldn't go but i
forget what i have i couldn't go so I I
think I've sort of been invited once and
almost invited another time although at
the rate things are going maybe the
Trump transition team will invite you
for a job mm-hmm press secretary dan
Patrick about director of sports that's
perfect and with all the trump golf
courses yep and you could do that you
could do the show from there the Dennis
may not all get security clearance one
I think you're on Twitter now well I won
one day Annette was just shaking his
head yes he's probably not going to get
clearly yeah i'm not i'm not saying any
names here i'm not in front of the TV i
don't know which one it's eaten yeah see
okay I see where you're putting in a
full day on sunday is your calling the
game on Sunday night well well you you
pretend like co-hosting football night
in America with you is not a full day I
know you carry most of the show but I I
do consider a full workday dan do you
get paid per segment on Sunday uh no no
i do not i'm i'm always there ready just
in case for the other things I i watch
the other segments with you Robbie and
Tony that you know what people don't
realize it can I just can I just brag
about you for 20 20 seconds I'll take
take longer okay thank you people don't
realize how hard that job is because its
height highlights the window is very
small the late games are going on while
you guys are on the air and it's so
seamless with Tony and Rodney and that's
because you do those highlights so well
and there's the thing about Dan but I'm
sure gonna brag about your first few
seconds when you don't do something but
once a week and do it for about 18 weeks
it's hard to hop in and just be great at
it and you hop in and do football
highlights like you were doing sports
center highlights with when we were
doing 20 highlights at night you could
do a highlight in your sleep but now you
don't do it but once a week for a third
of the year and I just I watched from
the set and I just think it's just
awesome I I just really enjoy the show
because of you thank you Mike I mean
that I'm serious there was no sucking up
or anything you got the job you got the
job all right oh I didn't know you got
me hired bad forgot thank you but okay
but you're so you're doing sunday night
i am i am doing sunday then thanksgiving
night and then the following sunday so
you got your master plan put in place
where you got a lout of the booth so
well done oh wow if you
before dawn I bet if that is terrible
after you just complimented me and thank
you good friend you are yeah it might it
might be true but it's very insensitive
it's old man there you know one thing
about the one thing about being the sub
host of football night in America since
you obviously tell us a good a main host
uh if it has been traveling with Al and
Chris and Michelle and the oh group
ready Delhi dress costs everybody but al
has a story on everything and the detail
is just the best like you bring up a
baseball game and its sixth inning it
was 22 discount at this picture he's
just he's just the best and hanging with
him in Rio and then now every week it's
been for a guy who is a nerd about this
part of the business and loved sports
it's been like the thrill of a lifetime
it's so much fun to be around him and
he's been unbelievably gracious about me
hopping in to do a couple of games or he
gets a chance to recharge and then back
at it for the rest of the run yeah I
tell people that I didn't know how and I
didn't have a relationship with him you
know I'd have him on occasionally or I'd
see him but when I went to London and
got to go to dinner with him every night
and you're right his memory is it's
startling the the attention to detail
that he will know he'll know what the
weather was like that night right he'll
tell you everything and I go con he he's
incredible he's forgotten more things
than I know he has so much information
now he's he's great and you see you see
why you see why that whole group now
being with them you see why they're so
good its attention to every small detail
so it's uh it's it's a big it's a big
seat to sit in just to do it for a few
games will be will be a thrill to be a
lot of fun and you know chris's as good
as goods again so it'll be it'll be
enjoyable for sure it's nice to be here
and preparing for a game and you know so
god who's the backup left tackle and
when did he play and does he switched a
guard or Center I've missed that that
was part of my life every week for 20
weeks last ten years so it's nice to get
back to sleep deprivation again thursday
night football tonight coverage begins
at seven thirty eastern on NBC in the
NFL network
it will be Carolina and the Saints now
you'll have green bay on sunday how much
of a topic is aaron rodgers Mike
McCarthy how prominent will that be I'm
sure it will be it will be a significant
one and we'll talk to both of them as we
get closer to the game here in the next
day or two it's an interesting dynamic
you know in a few places i'm thinking of
new orleans to with breeze and painted
for a long time the Giants with Coughlin
Eli and obviously get Brady and Ben and
Brady and Bill and then Ben and Mike
Tomlin in New England in Pittsburgh
respectively you get a great quarterback
and the coach was very good as well and
they stayed together for a while so
there's going to be some rockiness in
the past there and Aaron's very steep
he's very thoughtful and very deep and
people were wondering with Aaron in some
ways being critical of Mike with his
comments after the game and Aaron came
out yesterday in their open locker room
says that this kind of shot all that
down there probably now they can't run
the ball but let's let's forget
everything else Aaron's made some
mistakes they can't run the ball
effectively enough they've become one
dimensional and they're going to need to
get back to mixing in some run to have a
chance here down the stretch i think
Detroit's decent I'm not if they're
really good I think they're good enough
to be a nine-win team so Green Bay's
gonna have to get some work done here
they cannot afford to lose many more
games of the stretch Mike have fun
tonight and obviously on Sunday with a
full time job on Sunday we wish you I
wish you the best of luck putting in a
full day's work there on sunday night
football are they gonna have at NBC
football game without the two of us
tonight it feels like that Wow are you
okay with that yeah yes I am yes I I
love watching other people work Mike I
do thanks thanks buddy all right that's
Mike Tirico he's got sunday night
packers Redskins big doin's there with
Aaron Rodgers Mike McCarthy I'll said
Mike Florio is involved in this and
Aaron Rodgers calling out Mike Florio we
got some drama here
got some drama the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience